[Music]  I'll do my part and and I can't wait  baby Chmerkovskiy has finally arrived  congrats are in order for maxim and peta  murgatroyd as the Dancing with the Stars  duo welcomed their first child a baby  boy he's like literally the love of my  life the two lovebirds have been  documenting pitas pregnancy journey  leading up to their son's arrival  sharing sweet baby bump photos on social  media like this one captioned bump watch  max also adorably practice for his  upcoming daddy duties in October with  diaper changing drills supposed to be  super simple all right so his butt like  goes right here but let's go to bang  bang bang bang and then this goes and  that goes boom and the pair even gave  their followers a peek inside their  lavish baby shower in December  you